hello everyone and welcome to how to
build a performance-based influencer
marketing strategy traditional marketing
methods are becoming less effective but
influencer marketing is gaining power as
a way to attract the convert customers
online
part of me everyone I drop my notes and
okay let's take another stab at this so
anyway so good morning everyone we're
talking about how to build a performance
base more influencer marketing strategy
and we're going to be here with Matt
Bailey who's the bestselling author and
digital marketing expert as he discusses
the steps involved in implementing an
effective influencer marketing strategy
for your organization now by default
I just want to indicate that we have
some slides to show you here and what's
going to happen is that everyone is
muted and if you want to ask a question
then all you have to do is click on the
chat icon in the upper right hand corner
of the WebEx meeting center and the chat
window will appear in the lower right
from the drop-down select a participant
to address your message to select host
and presenter and in the chat box type
your question or comment and then click
the send button now you can also raise
your hand with the raise your hand icon
and a host will contact you via live
chat
so just for
in addition to the chat function in
WebEx you could also join us for a live
chat on Twitter by following us and
tagging at simply learned in your
questions now you can also join us on
YouTube live just type they simply learn
just type simply learn into the search
bar on YouTube and be sure to subscribe
to receive alerts for all upcoming
YouTube live videos now I'd like to
introduce you to Matt Bailey who is the
best-selling author marketing expert in
corporate trainer and a professional
speaker is also the founder and
president of site logic marketing is
that our site logic marketing now Matt
is a digital marketing instructor for
the digit for the Direct Marketing
Association in New York City and a
member of the digital marketing faculty
here at simply learned he is the author
of a number of books including internet
marketing an hour a day wired to be
wowed and a new book teach new dogs old
tricks so Matt thank you again for
joining us how are you doing today
oh hello Matt how are you all right Dan
how you doing today I'm pretty good
we've got the lots of lots of
microphones going on here with anybody
so that's a that's how we are in this
first Tuesday after daylight saving time
begins absolutely too many buttons I
think we just need one all right right
great well thank you for joining us so
we're going to go ahead and hand over
control of this party to you all right
all right thank you very much and thank
you everyone for joining us today on
this webinar and just as a mile-high
overview the things we're going to cover
really understanding how influencers
influence us and also if you are
considering looking at influence or
marketing things that you can do to
screen potential influencers look at how
well they may work with your company or
your brand and also setting expectations
as far as what type of payment or
compensation might be expected for what
kind of content extent mala GMAT is yeah
haha all right my window disappeared
here let me see
you
that should be working now
great thank you Matt and thank you thank
you Ovid or for pointing it out to us so
wait just one button one button that's
all I needed
if I were king we'd have one button all
right thanks thanks Matt let's uh let's
take it yeah I think it's doing through
the top again thank you very much all
right well there's only been one slide
here so I think we're good we're going
to look at how influencers influence us
out of screen potential influencers and
then also what do you get for what you
pay for and I think probably the most
important aspect of working with
influencers is how to manage the
relationship and Balance brand control
those are some of the biggest issues
when we get into influencer marketing
that brands may be unprepared for as
well as trying to figure out before they
even get into a relationship with an
influencer what to expect and how this
will all unfold now just a high-level
view of some of the trends is that you
know YouTube is the new celebrity maker
some of us at a certain age may have
grown up with network television and
maybe a few limited channels and the
stars were the ones that were on those
channels there were regular TV shows and
actors and actresses and so the pool of
celebrity was very small now with
digital media YouTube Instagram all
types of social media be it's one study
showed that children under 13 recognized
more YouTube personalities then they
recognized television personalities and
so YouTube and Instagram have become the
influencers of the new generation
influencer marketing of course because
of its accessibility as well as the
growth of celebrity or influencers is
increasing and so brands are jumping all
over this to get in early now the other
side of this is that there is high risk
high
Ward at this point because it is so new
there are a lot of brands getting into
it that are unprepared for what may they
may fall into but also in working with
influencers themselves some don't have
any business experience whatsoever and
so you are putting your brand into the
hands of someone who may be very young
and very inexperienced and there has
been some backfires when it comes to
working with different influencers so at
this point being very early it's a shiny
object it's a trend and there's
high-risk high-reward and as long as you
are prepared for that moving in you'll
be alright now one thing that we do need
to understand and this is something that
I have to educate people as well as
potential clients about this all the
time is that there is no such thing as
going viral anymore the concept of
someone creating a piece of content and
it just goes viral because it's so good
is really outdated and out the door for
years now
the concept of going viral has been
co-opted and in order for something to
go viral today you can bet that there
are a number of advertisers there are
agencies there are paid influencers
there are mass accounts on social sites
there is a lot of money and a lot of
people involved for something to go
viral anymore and accidentally the
chances of it happening are slim to
absolutely none most viral ads viral
content viral videos or anything that's
called viral is the result of
influencers agencies and a carefully
planned network of making something go
viral and so especially if you're
working with someone and their their
goal is to try and create something that
will go viral unless you've got a large
budget and a lot of people the chances
of that happening are very small
now when we start talking about
influencers there are a number of levels
of influences that we can look at the
first level of influencers are the ones
that are the typical influencers and
those are the actors singers sports
personalities or fashion personalities
also reality TV has given us a number of
personalities so that goes into the area
of celebrity the number one followed
celebrity is Selena Gomez she is
followed by more than any other
celebrity singer or personality right
now in the world now what has created
this influence or marketing or then what
are called the macro influencers these
are people that have more than a million
followers so in the fashion industry
Arielle Charnas is probably the number
one influencer she has over 1 million
Instagram followers and over 26,000
followers of her Facebook account she
has a blog that she's had for well over
ten years called something Navy and the
numbers of her subscribers to the blog
are not readily available but they I am
sure number in the millions now also
like I said YouTube is the new star
maker good mythical morning is a morning
talk show that takes place on YouTube
there are over 13 million regular
subscribers that does not count the
people that just go watch it or
streaming and then also Dan PDM he does
daily gaming videos where he walks
through games or plays games or has
friends online and he is over 18 million
subscribers so as you can see here the
number of media has increased
dramatically the number of ways for
personalities to be developed as well as
to develop followers and influence those
followers has increased substantially
now also beyond the macro influencers
there are the micro influencers this is
really where influencer marketing has
really started to develop a sweet spot
micro influencers typically have
audiences between 10,000 and a hundred
thousand and what I like about micro
influencers is that they are typically
focused on a specific industry or a
specific area of interest you'll find
micro influencers who are travel
bloggers food bloggers they use
Instagram Pinterest they're also in
fashion or home decorating they
typically have a passion about about a
specific area and they publish in that
area and they vary between mediums some
are more focused on blogs some are in
instagrams some are on YouTube but what
makes this a sweet spot for advertisers
is that they're focused in a specific
area and so the relationship aspect with
a brand is right there for a brand that
is in that industry or in that area or
wants to reach their subscribers who
have that specific interest now also
this gets into travel you can see this a
lot in photography and then also within
travel photography food fashion you see
these niches arise that there is
adventure photography or adventure
filmography there is these niche areas
that are evolving even within the micro
influencers and so there are specialty
food specialty travel specialty food
revolves typically maybe around wine or
on gluten-free diets and so even though
you can group this into larger groups
such as travel or food there are always
these micro niche industries that tend
to be arising
just a quick overview over who is an
influencer and what can you typically
expect from an influencer in the
different levels of influencers now
here's the bottom line
influencers will extend your reach if
you work with them but it is for a price
now Old Navy works with both macro
influencers and micro influencers one
example is a campaign they have with a
fashion blogger or or more of what we
would call a home maker blogger and
Megan reaches over 1 million followers
the campaign with Odin ad reached over 1
million followers
she has over 2.3 million subscribers to
her YouTube channel now in combining
with Old Navy and working with some of
their clothing and fashion Old Navy was
able to gain some of Megan's subscribers
to their social channels she just styles
Old Navy products clothing shows people
how they can be used and implements them
in her blogging and in her videos now
really does influencer marketing work
what does it do for us now it's
interesting because there have been a
couple of tests and studies done but
really when you look throughout modern
history advertising has always featured
celebrity I went back and even found
some old Frank Sinatra ads it was
interesting because most of them for
cigarettes and why have celebrities
always been used to sell product well it
turns out that our brains are actually
wired to be attracted to celebrities
there was a Dutch study done with women
where when women looked at photos of
celebrities it activated a part of the
brain the medial orbitofrontal cortex
now that medial orbitofrontal cortex is
associated with feelings of affection
that would we recognize and have
feelings of affection that part of our
brain fires up
and so that Dutch study found that when
women were looking particularly at
celebrities that part of the brain was
activated in a UK study people were
asked to look at what they considered
average looking celebrities as opposed
to beautiful non celebrities when people
looked at the ads that ad celebrities
there was a more intense emotional
response in a similar part of the brain
and so it's very interesting that our
brains just seem to be wired for
celebrity we feel as though we have some
connection with them there is affection
there and we tend to know them now I
found it interesting that even my own
personal experience is that I was in Las
Vegas for a show and while I was there
the guys from top gear top gear is a
British show on cars and actually the
the host to move on and created a new
show called the Grand Tour but I was in
the same room with the guys from Top
Gear and my first inclination when I saw
them and made eye contact was to wave as
if somehow they would know me yet it was
all one-sided I knew them I knew their
personalities from being exposed to them
on television and listening to them and
watching them but they didn't know me
but yet somehow there was that sense of
familiarity and advertizing understands
this in fact over the past decade the
number of celebrities has more than
quadrupled think about it with new
channels such as HDTV food TV reality
shows YouTube personalities contest
shows the number of who qualifies as a
celebrity is just being increased daily
and the media has a vested interest in
creating these celebrities because ads
with celebrities have more than doubled
in the past few years and now it's
estimated that one in four ads feature a
celebrity the industry knows that
celebrities sell
and so the industry creates more
celebrities to sell more we're wired to
be connected to celebrities now also
whenever you tie your brand with an
influencer it will increase followers a
couple of examples campaign examples are
one of the Super Bowls there was Howdy
was partnering with snapchat
personalities during the day of the game
these snapchat personalities we're just
putting out I love these
this picture here that dog doesn't care
who wins
it was photographs with funny headlines
that really had nothing to do with the
game in fact it really disparaged the
game that they didn't care what was
going to happen now Odie there were
netted 2500 new Twitter followers and
9,000 new Facebook fans there was about
37 million impressions about 2400
campaign mentions and about a hundred
thousand views on snapchat and new
snapchat followers so Odie was able to
partner with this influencer and because
of that they gained new followers they
gained new views and new fans on the
other side of the screen here we can see
here is Logan Paul partnered with sour
patch and sour patches of candy and they
went around New York and did a prank
campaign and by partnering with Logan
Paul sour patch gained 120,000 new
snapchat followers and it was about six
almost seven million impressions
generated over 500,000 on one day more
than 26,000 screenshots and about 1,900
Twitter mentions from that campaign so
we know that when a brand partners with
an influencer that brand gains more
followers and gains more visibility now
what can you expect though for these
numbers what's the typical price what do
you get out of that well tip
pricing is if you go to a a high-end
blogger a a macro blogger you can expect
a single tweak to run between 50 or $100
now when you go to a high-visibility
blogger or vlogger vlogger is a video
blogger so these are people to have a
youtube channel and that's the primary
means of communicating if you go to them
for a single video it can run as high as
$100,000 but what the Logan Falls sour
patch campaign ran was about a thousand
dollars or a hundred thousand dollars
per video a single review from a popular
blogger can run a brand as about as much
as ten thousand dollars an example this
is honda paid about ten thousand dollars
for a two minute video with an
influencer now what you can expect
typically is about $100,000 for an
influencer who has over five million
followers to create one video post for
each platform and that's typically
YouTube Facebook snapchat
maybe Instagram depending upon what you
agree and so as you can see the cost can
go up dramatically depending upon who
you're working with now this is why also
micro influencers are coming in to
popularity is because they don't cost as
much and also they influence a smaller
group of people but a smaller group of
people that have something in common
you see if you partner with a
high-visibility or a macro influencer
they're following this person because
they're entertaining but really there is
not a specific affinity group based on a
passion or a like or a hobby or
something like that
it's more based on the entertainment
value where is your micro influencers
they have that affinity group whether
it's photography traveler food or
fashion or decor something like that and
so it's easier for a brand to partner
with a micro influencer and have some
specific relevance
now not all campaigns are expensive for
example Sephora which is a beauty brand
built-in insider community that they
call beauty talk and while they do
provide free product to reviewers and
bloggers and fashion celebrities those
celebrities and influencers they come
back to this community called beauty
talk and they leave very honest and open
product reviews
what Sephora has encouraged is let us
know what you like what you don't like
give your opinion because some are going
to like the product and some are not and
what they've realized is especially when
it comes to beauty products not
everything works great for everyone and
so by hearing different opinions and
hearing what's good and what's bad you
can make your own determination based on
your skin your coloring your needs or
your preferences and so getting the good
and bad from multiple sources Sephora
has found that that is a great method of
being honest and authentic also another
fashion or beauty a site called glossy
err they really focus on what they call
regular women micro influencers and 90%
of the revenue comes from these highly
engaged regular women rather than
utilizing macro influencers or micro
influencers they're just using their
everyday customers and featuring them
and highlighting them in order to create
a community of followers many other
brands have chosen to highlight
employees or even customer stories and
in doing so it presents a very human
relatable story to the outside world and
we're fascinated with behind the scenes
of companies and how they work and what
people do and also many customer stories
or employee stories they're great
stories and stories engage us so it
doesn't have to be an influencer
marketing campaign does not have to be
a hundred thousand or $500,000 campaign
for a brand many times is just looking
for the stories that may be in your own
company that your customers may have or
even allowing your customers to engage
with you in different ways
now the second part of working with
influencers is being aware as a brand
when you approach an influencer being
aware of the numbers and their followers
now this is the latest shiny thing as I
said and many times there are how should
I say this bloggers influencers that
aren't really they're really too honest
when it comes to talking about their
follower numbers in fact it's not too
hard to go online and find ways to buy
followers or to buy likes uh and time
sometimes there are hidden relationships
and questions about just how influential
are they they might have a lot of
followers but where is the influence can
that influence be measured can it be
valued at any method so you may want to
ask about past campaigns that this
influencer has run who else they've
worked with and maybe talked to them in
order to know what previous campaigns or
previous brand experiences have had and
so you can get more of an idea of the
actual depth of influence that this
influencer has we can also because of
these methods of over inflating follower
numbers or likes or think engagement
numbers it becomes a question of
credibility so for example there is a
site here called buzz eyed where I could
go and I can buy followers I can buy -
let me see here twenty five hundred
followers for 30 dollars I can buy five
thousand likes for forty dollars as you
can see it's not a lot of money anyone
can go boost their follower or like
numbers and make it look like they have
more followers and more engagement than
they really do and in fact it doesn't
take much just go look at the news and
look at click forms there are click
farms that are out there that all they
do is follow personalities and like
their status like what they're doing and
they follow them and it can be very
misleading
so be aware of the influencers that you
are looking at and there are some
services out there that will help you do
an audit of those follower numbers just
be aware that really this is an arms
race as soon as software can detect
which followers are BOTS or software
generated and not humans guess what the
clip farms get better and so just as
someone says we can detect who's real
and who's not someone's going to find a
better way to overcome that detection
because this is big business the more
followers I have the more money I can
charge and so not all are going to be
honest and upfront about how many
followers they have or the engagement or
depth of influence that they have and so
at this point it's still good to into
the services that will offer some sort
of audit of the actual number of
followers something else that is vital
is to look at the history of that
influencer and look at their history of
disclosure when working with brands over
90% of celebrities who do social media
endorsements violate FTC regulations and
this is prosecutable the FTC has become
the Federal Trade Commission here in the
US has become a lot more active in
pursuing social media personalities who
did not disclose brand relationships
they're also going after the brands and
Europe the EU is becoming much more
active in going after brands and
personalities that do not disclose
advertising relationships in this
example here Margot Robbie was at
Glastonbury and she was tagging herself
and tagging these Hunter boots that she
had on now originally she hashtagged it
with AD however it was deleted shortly
afterwards and so her followers were
confused was the original hashtag a
mistake or was this really a paid post
not really sure what was going on so
sometimes it can be labeled as an ad and
sometimes it's not but what they have
found in surveys is that the vast
majority of celebrities social media
endorsements do not contain the hashtag
ad which is the simplest and easiest way
to disclose the relationship now in a
survey that was done this year social
influencers were asked do you label
advertising content as sponsored as
advertising content only 52% of
influencers said yes we label content as
sponsored all the time 41% said they
will only label content as an ad when
they are specifically asked by the brand
to label it that way the problem has
become that there are brands that know
that if it's labeled as an ad it doesn't
get as much engagement and so sometimes
the brand will put pressure on the
influencer to use the product but not
disclose it as an ad that can get you
into trouble with the FTC with the EU
with many other organising bodies that
are due consumer protection this is an
act in fact there is 7% of influencers
who say that they will never into that
they will never label content as
sponsored this is the responsibility of
both the brand and the influencer to
mark appropriate content as sponsored or
as advertising will get a little more
into this but this is a very very
critical issue and one that both brands
and influencers need to be serious about
because it's not going away and the
government both in the US and in Europe
and in other countries are looking at
these relationships much more closely
and so be aware that this can be a
pitfall if you try to bypass this in
order to get more engagement
now the third thing about influencer
marketing that's vitally important is
not to forget about measurement most
people will develop these brands in
order to get more followers but they
don't at the beginning of the campaign
sit down and decide well what do we want
from it now you can use some
transactional tracking if you're doing a
promotion you can have discount codes
that that influencer can give to their
followers you can develop individual
landing pages or tag links that's one
way now one brand or one study by
Thomas's said that businesses are
getting six dollars and fifty cents in
revenue for every dollar spent on
influencer marketing
however in Colton's a consultancy did
another report and said that ROI is one
of the biggest challenges for brands so
it's very interesting that when you're
researching and looking at different
headlines you're going to find very
different views on influencer marketing
in fact here we see one is saying the
ROI is fantastic the other one is saying
the vast majority of people can't
calculate an ROI in fact one brand the
orchid islands used company
Natalie Sexton there is director
marketing and she says you have no way
of knowing what kind of impact snapchat
is making for your brand so you need to
decide what you want from the campaign
and how you're going to develop the
campaign around that so begin with the
end result in mind what do you want and
I will tell you from a brand perspective
avoid terms like engagement and
awareness those terms are so fuzzy for
lack of a better term they're so devoid
of actual meaning because engagement can
mean so many different things awareness
could mean so many different things that
don't really they aren't measurable they
don't track to actual actions they're
really just views and we think about how
many actual impressions are views the
average person sees in a day they're not
worth much so start with clear goals and
I like the acronym for SMART goals
create goals that are specific meaning I
want to increase sales by 3,000 in one
month or I want to increase my followers
on Twitter by 10% or I want at least
1,000 new customers or 1,000 new
followers those are specific and they're
also because their specific they're
measurable you'll know whether you reach
that or not make sure they're attainable
are they realistic and then also
time-based when do you want this to
happen this month this quarter this week
that is the way that you set an
attainable measurable SMART goal now you
can track with tracking pixels with
landing pages you can do cross
promotions coupon codes Instagram as a
comment to buy where you can click in
the comments and go buy the product and
that provides a level of a measurement
across the platform and then also within
YouTube videos there are links that can
appear during the video and you can
measure the click throughs and so the
social channels themselves are enabling
better ways to track engagement all the
way through to the sale or to the
conversion and so these actually are
going to get better through the channels
because it's in the channels best
interest to be able to provide tracking
tools and mechanisms for these
relationships now managing influencers
here's the issue
most of these influencers have gotten to
where they are based on the sheer weight
of personality most of these influencers
are very young most of your YouTube
personalities that have followers as
subscribers and the millions are in
their 20s some are their young 30s and
now they're being thrown hundreds of
thousands of dollars by brands to do
things to say things to promote a
product and this is a problem this is a
quote from an unnamed agency executive
that said influencers are still not
aware of some things that are very
obvious in marketing like sticking to a
schedule to them it's not important so
they'll just say oh do you know what
upper four I'd prefer to post this
Instagram tomorrow because I'm just not
feeling it today for marketers that's a
nightmare see the issue is a lot of
these influencers they don't have a
nine-to-five job no one's telling them
what to do and people are throwing money
at them to mention their brand talk
about their brand and no one tells them
what not to do they are surrounded by
people that are enjoying this just as
much as they are and so they do what
they want when they want because what
are you going to do as a brand are you
going to cancel the contract are you
going to end the relationship and so
many times you are working with very
young and sometimes very immature
influencers and they may not see your
schedule as being very important
especially if they're a part of a larger
campaign to them it's not going to be as
important as it is to you now probably
no story right now is bigger than what
has happened to logan paul logan paul
has probably about 12 to 13 million
subscribers on youtube he's probably one
of the most recognizable YouTube
personalities and the problem is that a
few months ago Logan Paul was in Japan
and he took his camera crew and they
won't look to what was called the
suicide forest it was called that
because that's where a lot of people go
to commit suicide and it just so
happened that while they were there they
found a body hanging from a tree this
goes to the immaturity of a lot of these
influencers rather than shutting down
the cameras and reporting it to
authorities they filmed it they filmed
it and they posted it Logan Paul posted
that video to his YouTube channel he
then had to take it down issue an
apology because the backlash was huge
you can see here Vanity Fair talking
about this is what's going on with these
youtube personalities they're realizing
that the bigger the thing they do the
more shocking it is the more subscribers
are going to have the more reviews
they'll have and the more views they
have the more money they make and so
Logan Paul has learned this there's no
such thing as bad press type of
mentality and after a while YouTube
reinstated him and within weeks have
reinstated him Logan Paul if you are
reading a headline
he used a Taser on a dead rat he also
said that he would eat Tide Pods as many
as the likes or retweets that I got
really very insensitive after just
posting something about someone
committing suicide so YouTube has cut
off his ad revenue it's been estimated
that his ad revenue is in the millions
of dollars per year you see it's not
taking long for these young
personalities to learn the more shocking
the more views the more money they make
and so what type of culture does this
create it creates this kind of culture
and brands I believe are just as guilty
of promoting it as the stars themselves
as the influencers themselves now a
little less shocking and a little less
serious are under an understanding that
when you rely on influencers to make a
brand pitch realize but many of them
simply don't care are inexperienced or
don't know how to casually do this one
example here is um it is Scott Disick I
don't know who he is but he's associated
with the Kardashians and in one of his
updates uh he simply did a copy and
paste you can tell that because the
update says here you go at 4 p.m. write
the below caption and not only did he
write the below caption but he just
simply copied and pasted the
instructions with the caption and so it
was very
obvious and one of the top comments was
that obviously you're being paid for
this Naomi nail who is another
influencer uh now she says the weather
has been so hot that she always carries
around a carton of her favorite miracle
peel fresh juice and of course this is
not neither of these are labeled as ads
there's not a hashtag ad or hashtag
sponsored so both of these are celebrity
endorsers who are talking about a
product without disclosing the
relationship and because of that the
comments it doesn't take much for
followers to figure out what's paid
what's not and when it's not disclosed
they can be ruthless as you can see the
top comment there was biggest sellout
ever they can see right through when
they're being sold - they can see where
there's a relationship so even though
you may be disclosing and disclosing an
ad may cause lower engagement or not as
much influence as you'd like as a brand
not disclosing it can cause serious
trouble with the followers and a lack of
credibility and an even further lack of
influence
now finally brand protection this is
what a lot of brands are concerned about
when they start working with influencers
because what influencers will tell you
is that in order to be authentic you
need to give over brand control you need
to give them complete control over the
message the style and what they're going
to do and their vision for how to
communicate your brand to their audience
it's very interesting in this Forbes
article the headline of the article was
improve influence or marketing for your
startup by letting go of creative
control that's the headline and I don't
like that because that's what you're
seeing all over the place influencers
are telling you hey you need to let go
of control this article in Forbes is
saying you need to let go but when you
read the article look at this quote what
they are actually saying is releasing
control not completely but just enough
well that's not what the headline said
the headline says let go of creative
control the article with the writer says
is release control not completely but
just enough that really is a
contradiction and so beware of headlines
that are telling you what you need to do
beware of headlines that are telling you
to release total control or read the
actual article because the article
actually made more sense than the
headline so be aware as a brand how much
control you're willing to give to an
influencer be it have some level of
approval of what the influencer is going
to do and what actually gets published
this actually is what ends a lot of
relationships is this struggle over
brand control and influence or control
be aware when you work go into an
influencer relationship of that brand
protection versus the influence or
control who has ultimate creative
control and also beware also of what the
influencer may say if you develop a long
term relationship with an influencer an
example of this was PewDiePie who was an
influencer and started doing a lot of
work with Disney and unfortunately
during that relationship Beauty pie
started making offensive statements
about Jews and of course came under fire
for that and of course Disney then had
to end the relationship but they were
associated with PewDiePie because he was
being paid to influence people for
Disney also look at the messaging who is
going to be in control of the messaging
who's going to give final approval about
the messaging and agreement on
disclosure these are things that need to
be developed at the beginning of the
relationship and not something that
needs to be handled after the
relationship returning the campaign is
coming together these need to be
addressed ahead of time now my biggest
take away here or my biggest piece of
advice insulate yourself from the hype
if you start googling articles on
influence or marketing or you start
looking at articles as far as how do I
do it or what should I look for five
biggest things I need to know like this
webinar it be aware of who's publishing
the article I found something very
interesting in the research here on
influencer marketing that the vast
majority of articles that you'll find in
search about influencer marketing number
one are written by influencers if the
influencers have a vested interest in
people doing influencer marketing it
raises the tide so to speak that if more
and more demand is there more people
will do it and the influencers benefit
you'd be amazed how many articles are
written about the power of influence or
marketing that are written by
influencers also the media the media
themselves are going to write this
because the media loves what's new it's
shiny it's new it's it gets headlines
and it gets clicks so the media is going
to write about things that are getting
clicks but I was also amazed at how many
consultants providers are writing
articles about the power of influencer
marketing I saw this at the end it was a
well ranking article on influencer
marketing and at the end of the article
if you have any questions or doubts let
me know and if you need professional
guidance launching your very own
influencer marketing campaign you'll
notice that's a link and if it's a link
with keywords in it so we've got the
search engine optimization going at the
same time so this is a consultant and a
provider writing an article about how
powerful influencer marketing is and
then pitching their own services at the
end of the article
be aware that this industry of influence
or marketing there is not a lot of
straightforward disclosure going on and
there's a lot of people invested into
this industry and making money on this
industry so educate yourself insulate
yourself from the hype be aware of the
advice you're getting into who's giving
you that advice I'll end with this in
working with influencers when I've
talked to brands that have done
campaigns with influencers
here's there are three things that they
found number one the right relationship
brands that have had a very successful
influencer relationship utilized an
influencer that liked the brand already
or was already a fan of the brand or
used the product that was already an
existing relationship between the
influencer and the product and so the
brand in utilizing that was able to then
create something and the message became
much more authentic because the
influencer was already a fan or a user
of the product look for an influencer
that's got the best audience or a
perfect fit audience look for
influencers that have an audience that
has an affinity to your brand or your
product already you see if you go macro
influencer there's no infinity group if
you start calling micro influencers or
something that makes sense for your
brand and because the audience has an
affinity in a relatable relevant group
it works and then also the right mix of
allowing creative voice to the
influencer but also an influencer an
influencer who recognizes the need for
brand control and brand messaging
finding an influencer who will work with
you not against you that wants to
promote and see the best for your brand
rather than just get a payday and likes
the brand and has an audience that has
an affinity for your relatable relevant
product that's
best mix and that has been a consistent
scenario for brands that have had
successful forays into influencer
marketing now quick resource that I
would give you is the FTC guidelines on
endorsements now as you can see the link
here goes off the page I shortened it
it's a bitly link for FTC d IFC for
disclosure and so if you want to write
that down very quickly it's bit Lee /
FTC di SC alright that wraps set up for
me we'll take some questions but if
you'd like to find me online I'm on
LinkedIn Matt Bailey site logic and
Twitter at site logic and Dan I'm going
to hand it over to you great Thank You
Matt that was a that was really
informative and we have a we have a lot
of great questions coming in on
particularly on our feed on YouTube so
you talked a bit about the the tools
that you have or for actually finding
influencers and what is your favorite
tool for finding in posers I know that
there's followerwonk and yeah zoom oh um
you know I I tend to do the organic
thing I search um I just search to see
who has visibility um that tends to for
me that means it's got a cross-channel
appeal it's something that will not only
work in social but it will also work in
search which increases appeal it goes to
multiple channels which means that will
last longer so I you know I I use search
more than I use tools just because I
think it gives me a better idea but then
also I just tend to click and follow
networks of people I look for more of an
organic approach I think is what I do
yeah and well I guess if you're if
you're influencer doesn't have good SEO
then that's a hugger didn't boot sir are
there are they so yeah you know and
that's a great let me I'm going to go
off on the side on that I have found
so for example I work with one blogger
she's been a blogger probably for about
eight to ten years now her search is
fantastic but you know she has never
taken one course or read one article on
SEO she's just a great writer and
content is king it is it is and so I
love finding people like that that's
great you know here's a here's another
question and this has to do with right
at the very beginning you were talking
about the celebrity effect on the brain
where people are really affected by how
much affection they have for people in
their celebrity and this is I don't know
if you know they answer this but
someone's asking so in order for this
celebrity effect to occur does the
influencer have to already be a
celebrity known to the viewer or can the
viewers simply be just told that their
celebrity in order for that effect to
take place it's I believe it's a
recognizable issue um it's one where I
recognize them because part of how this
affects our brain is we put the
characteristics of the celebrity on the
product okay and so the personality what
we like about that celebrity we assign
that likability or those characteristics
to the product that they are endorsing
and so we buy that product because
ultimately it's kind of like we want to
be like them they have qualities we
admire and now those qualities we it's
just interesting how subconsciously this
happens in our brain we just assign
those same qualities to the products
that they like so it has to be a
recognizable celebrity simply being told
if not enough it's more of a you know
you watch that show you like their
acting you like their singing and so you
follow them that's more of what that so
that appeal of celebrity is yeah well
that makes sense but as I mentioned also
couldn't hurt to to introduce them as
just like we introduce introduce you and
introducing any speakers I'm sure it's
up to credibility as well when people go
this actually is somebody that's
you know not just some day that there's
talking but couldn't hurt I guess but
that that makes a good point that yeah
they have to that that's that's a great
observation that people ascribe the
emotions that have for that celebrity on
to the product so really a sense well
it's kind of like so you know a couple
years ago Rachael Ray came out with room
cookware who cared if it was good
cosplay or cookware that is that she
just it's Rachael Ray so it must be good
they ascribed her personality to a set
of cookware so it's just real
interesting how our brain just wires
that together yeah even if the celebrity
has nothing to do with the product just
like you said absolutely yeah so here's
another question which is we were
talking you talked about the regulations
regarding what about disclosure and all
that sort of thing but and I know that
you can't specifically tell the
influencer what to say but is it fair to
ask your influencers for a draft of
their content before they post it on the
internet oh absolutely absolutely
um you know the one example I gave of
someone copying pasting the update it's
just funny because that update was
probably it was probably two copywriters
uh you know an ad an exec an account rep
probably all sweating over what kind of
update to make and then they sent it and
it was copy pasted so some influences
are going to want you to do it uh others
yes they'll come up with it but I think
it's very fair to ask for a draft or
final approval great well thanks I'm
trying to figure out this this question
is similar to what we talked about
before when we were talking about
finding inclusions and that but someone
is asking so what is the best website
website specifically for authentically
dealing with Instagram influencers do
you have any suggestions there as far as
finding like yeah whose video system
who's the best if you wanted to find
someone that was specifically the top
name on on
who the best person I guess Hannibal
yeah for who the best influencer would
be on the Instagram platform what are
some oh yeah I you know what I should
have a list of their there are some
programs out there that will give you
lists of followers um and and it's
interesting because everyone's going to
have a different list or a different
algorithm to determine who's more
influential um and so there's there's
not a lot of consistency among different
programs and its really finding the
program that you I guess you like for
your purposes I in different industries
I've seen different results different uh
types and so part of this is that I
wouldn't rely on software number one I
wouldn't rely on an agency I would use
an agency if you're doing this for
guidance but ultimately I'm not just
looking for the top Instagram uh in term
Instagram influencer in terms of numbers
okay there's a difference between and
this get into what's called depth of
influence just because they may have two
million followers does not mean they
have a depth of influence of two million
people I may find that an Instagram
personality with less than a million but
yet when you look in their engagement
statistics they're averaging maybe
fifteen you know 18 percent engagement
of those 1 million followers whereas
another influence or may have two
million followers but they have maybe
one percent or two percent engagement um
so that's what's called depth of
influence and software won't always give
you that I mean they're working on it
but these are they're really running on
algorithmic calculations I'm also
looking at the personality the
personality you know
is it warm is it cold
is it you know what's the personality
like and how do they talk about other
brands and how do they engage with their
followers there's much more I think
intangible that I look for rather than
just sheer numbers of how many followers
how many likes that type of thing I'm
looking more at the person yeah that's a
particularly helpers yeah especially
because if branding is important to you
you definitely want to have an
influencer who is on brand so here's a
here's an easy question I don't know if
it's easy it's very basic and someone is
outright asking what is OK Facebook or
influencer marketing and this is for the
e-commerce domain what the where would
you put your money Oh
Facebook or influencer I would be like
Facebook ad ya mean absolutely the only
way to do Facebook now right right yeah
um I would honestly I would go more
targeted programmatic buying on Facebook
than I would do influencer hmm
interesting okay yeah great yeah so
let's see we have another question here
is how does influence from marketing
affect your own SEO you know again it
comes down to what they're doing if
they're a blogger then that will
directly affect your SEO because you're
getting a link from a blog and that's
going to be there now forever same with
Pinterest Pinterest is very evergreen
Pinterest doesn't get old and so that's
always there I'm amazed idea the one
mommy blogger I work with um don't take
offense it's just where she is she's a
mommy blogger uh the vast majority of
her traffic comes from Pinterest that is
like her primary channel and so the SEO
of Pinterest is very high now if they're
Instagram it doesn't really seem to
affect SEO much because it's in the
moment and it goes away
YouTube tends to have some sticking
our so it depends on what their primary
channel is how well it will affect or
improve your own SEO and also how long
it will last
great that's a that's certainly helpful
so we have a lot of good questions
coming in so we also have another
question this is a first one see if I
can understand this which is how do you
find is there a way that you can [ __ ] if
you want to go in the offline side of
influencers for example magazines like
premium publications likes or even or
even publications that have websites
like like slate Huffington like can you
provide any customized mainly though I
think the person is asking for specific
outreach templates like how do you
approach people like this I mean other
source for for advice on on how to link
approach these people on these these
complications but you know what that
could be its own webinar is how to
approach influencers because honestly
most people do a terrible job of
pitching influencers yeah um and there's
a whole industry now of people who think
they're influencers and they're going
after brands and telling brands to give
them free stuff because there's such a
good influencer which is just ridiculous
because usually the brand or the company
has more followers than they do so
there's not there is a template if
you're going to contact an influencer
you are a brand and you want to contact
an influencer give up the best advice I
give you is consider the what's in it
for me approach and I don't mean from
the brand perspective if you're going to
an influencer to work with you as a
brand you need to pitch it in terms of
what's in it for them what benefit does
they get what benefit do their
subscribers get what how will it benefit
them the worst pitches I get are from
people who tell me how great they are
and what they'll bring to me and that
brands get you know employers it's the
same thing 99% of the pitches you did
are from brands that are telling the
influencer how great they are and how
awesome they are
but there's nothing as far as well what
is the influencer get right oh that's
number one number two is hi there is no
standard method of influencing it
influencing it can be everything from
getting free product for reviews so a
brand I give you I give this influencer
or free product and they use it and they
give a review it can be uh it you know
you know simply paying to write a review
or um you know developing a content
series or a video series you know it
really is an amazing amount of ways that
content can be produced through an
influencer relationship so it's it's not
just simply I'm paying you to make a
video or I'm paying you to say something
look at creative ways to develop it
great I think the last part of this
question is is are there ways to if you
don't have a lot of money what do you
suggest as means to compensate
influencers is there anything other than
cold hard cash yeah you know what
there's um you know for example there is
I'm trying to think of one situation how
it worked out but a brand
it was a software-as-a-service and they
found that an influencer was using their
service and so they approached the
influencer saying hey you know you love
using our service can we develop a
relationship and ultimately what they
did was they gave the influencer free
access and then they gave him a
promotion code and that influencer was
then essentially now an affiliate and so
whenever someone asked the influencer
you know what are you using and what you
know so he gave him a promotional code
or sometimes he would just announce the
promotional code while he was on the
circuit and in that way there was no out
of pocket for the brand all they did was
create an affiliate relationship hmm
that's great great idea so well that's
actually all the questions that we have
time for for now now if if you and if
anyone that is on the webinar remaining
that wants to ask a question via chat
you can go ahead and continue to do that
for a moment here while we wrap up and
then we can always respond you later on
we'll also be checking further questions
on YouTube and as those come in we'll be
able to answer those as well I just want
to take a moment now to say thanks again
to Matt Bailey for joining us today and
what a reminder want to remind our
audience that you can re-watch and share
this webinar instantly on YouTube right
now and for all those of you who
registered through WebEx please keep an
eye out for follow-up emails next week
and we'll even have a written wrap-up of
this webinar including another copy of
the video and more so also stay tuned as
soon as this session ends we're going to
have a little pop up of a survey would
be very helpful
to us if you could answer a couple of
those questions to let us know how we
can serve you better and of course
remember to follow Matt on LinkedIn and
for more information give us an email
here as well so if you have any further
questions like I say feel free to send
us a message and we will get back to you
for a full schedule of upcoming webinars
and events please head over to our
Facebook page on searching on simply
learn so Matt thank you very much again
for the very influential webinar thanks
everyone 0 noise thank you for joining
us all bye bye bye
you
you
you